Joe do you answer the question about the
Super Bowl 3 thinking back on it now did
you make love the night of Super but you
did the night before you did because
that's how you win games that's that was
your modus operandi is that what the
colts forgot the culture to buy Bankim
you did have sex tonight before I would
think you would be so nervous you know
what I mean like like that would be the
night although maybe out of respect to
my then girlfriend who was down there I
never told that story what do you mean
what do I mean there was a knock on the
door after curfew nope in other words
you were your head it happened to be a
lady from New York how did she know
where you were did you tell her I'm I
think somebody sent her because when we
were there she started chuckling after a
while she said my dad he'd go crazy if
she knows he's away he's in Baltimore oh
he's from Baltimore oh my god that's
amazing they tried to mess me up do you
get that paranoid did you say hey maybe
the Colts are up to something when I
gate was thought afterwards of course
though I thought that somebody was up to
something I thought it might have been
some wise guys that went the other way
and though she a great beauty this woman
she must have been she was yeah she was
nice cute as a waitress cocktail
waitress up here and did you have to be
on guard when you were with a woman like
that because I'm talking about the night
before the Super Bowl because just
because it's a story you know what I
mean you're Joe Namath it's a Super Bowl
is this well how would I've never said
that before in my life to anybody here
I'm telling you this is the first time
that I admitted to that really - what -
having sex the night was Super Bowl yeah
but the cocktail waitress from Baltimore
no less Wow
she might have she might have cost
Baltimore the whole show and I didn't
plan it I told you after the coach left
there was a knock on the door
you